coming up with the theory of everything
that unifies
uh general relativity and quantum field
theories um
is one of the big dreams of human
civilization
us descendants of apes wondering about
how this world works
so a lot of people dream what are your
thoughts about
sort of other outdoor ideas on theories
of
everything or unifying
theories so there's uh quantum loop
gravity
uh there's also more sort of uh like a
friend of mine eric weinstein
beginning to propose something called
geometric unity
so these kinds of attempts whether it's
through mathematical physics
or through other avenues or with stephen
wolfram a more computational view of the
universe
again in his case it's these hypergraphs
that are very tiny objects
as well similarly string theory
and trying to grapple with this world
what do you think
is there any of these uh theories that
are compelling to you that are
interesting
that may turn out to be true or at least
may turn out to contain
ideas that are useful yes i think the
latter i would say that the
containing ideas that are true is my
opinion was what
these some of these ideas might be for
example loop quantum gravity
is to me not a complete theory of
gravity in any sense but they have some
nuggets of truth in them
and typically what i expect happened i
have seen
examples of this within string theory
aspects which we didn't think are part
of string theory come to be part of it
for example i'll give you one example
string was believed to be 10 dimensional
and then there was this 11 dimensional
super gravity
and nobody know what the egg is that why
are we getting eleven dimensional super
gravity where a string is saying it
should be ten dimensional eleven was the
maximum dimension you can have a super
gravity
but string was saying sorry we are ten
dimensional
so for for a while we thought that
theory is wrong because how could this
be because string theory is definitely
theory of everything
we later learned that one of the circles
of string theory itself was
tiny that we had not appreciated that
fact and we discovered by doing thought
experiments and string theory that
there's got to be an extra circle
and that circle is connected to an 11
dimensional perspective
and that's what later on got called m
theory so
so so there are these kind of things
that you know we do not know what
exactly string theory is we're still
learning so we do not have a final
formulation of string theory
it very well could be that different
facets of different ideas come together
like loop quantum gravity or whatnot but
i wouldn't put them on par
namely loop quantum gravity is a scatter
of ideas
about what happens to space when they
get very tiny for example
you replace things by discrete data and
try to quantize it and so on
and you know it sounds like a natural
idea to quantize space
you know if you were naively trying to
do quantum space you might think about
trying to take points and put them
together in some
discrete fashion in some way that is
reminiscent of quantum gravity
string theory is more subtle than that
for example
i will just give you an example and this
is the kind of thing that we didn't put
in by hand we cut it out
and so it's more subtle than so what
happens if you squeeze the space to be
smaller and smaller
well you think that after a certain
distance
the notion of distance should break down
you know
when it goes smaller than planck scale
should break down what happens in string
theory we do not know the full answer to
that but we know the following name
if you take a space and bring it smaller
and smaller if the box gets smaller than
the planck scale by a factor of 10
it is equivalent by the duality
transformation to a space which is 10
times bigger
so there's a symmetry called a t duality
which takes
l to 1 over l well l is measured in
planck units
or more precise string units this
inversion
is a very subtle effect and i would not
have been or any physicist would not
have been able to design a theory which
has this property
that when you make the space smaller it
is as if you're making it bigger
that means there is no there's no
experiment you can do to distinguish the
size of the space
this is remarkable for example einstein
would have said of course i can measure
the size of the space what do i do well
i take a flashlight i send the light
around measure how long it takes for the
light to go around the space and
bring back and find the radius or
circumference of the the universe what's
the problem
i said well suppose you do that and you
shrink and say well it gets smaller and
smaller so what i said well
it turns out in string theory there are
two different kinds of photons
one photon measures one over l the other
one measures l
and so this duality reformulates and
when the space gets smaller it says oh
no you better use the bigger perspective
because the smaller one is harder to
deal with
so you do this one so so these examples
of loop quantum gravity have none of
these features these features that i'm
telling you about we have learned from
string theory
but they nevertheless have some of these
ideas like topological as gravity
aspects
are emphasized in the context of loop
quantum gravity in some form and so
these ideas might be there in some
kernel
in some corners of string there in fact
we i wrote a paper about topological
string theory and some connections with
potentially loop quantum gravity which
could be part of that so there are
little
facets of connections i wouldn't say
they're complete but i would say
most probably what will happen to some
of these ideas the good ones at least
they'll be absorbed within to string
theory if they're occurring
you